[Música]
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 y cero con solo estos
10 símbolos escribimos cualquier número
racional imaginable Pero por qué estos
símbolos en particular porque 10 y por
qué los colocamos como lo hacemos
los números han sido un hecho de la vida
a lo largo de la historia los primeros
humanos contaban animales en rebaño o
miembros de la tribu mediante partes del
cuerpo o rayitas conforme aumentaba la
complejidad de la vida y la cantidad de
cosas que contar estos métodos ya no
eran suficientes con el desarrollo de
las civilizaciones surgieron maneras de
registrar números más grandes muchos de
estos sistemas como el griego el hebreo
y los números egipcios eran solo
extensiones de rayitas que añadían
símbolos para representar valores
mayores cada símbolo se repetía Tantas
veces como fuera necesario y se
sumaba los números romanos agregaron
otro giro si un número aparecía antes de
otro de mayor valor se restaba en vez de
sumar pero incluso con esta Innovación
todavía era un método engorroso para
escribir grandes
números un sistema más útil y elegante
hacía uso de la notación
posicional los sistemas numéricos
anteriores debían plasmar muchos
símbolos repetidamente e inventaban un
símbolo nuevo para cada magnitud más
grande un sistema posicional podía
reutilizar los mismos símbolos
asignándoles diferentes valores según su
posición en la secuencia varias
civilizaciones desarrollaron la notación
posicional por su lado como los
babilonios los antiguos chinos y los
aztecas en el siglo vii los matemáticos
indios habían perfeccionado tal sistema
y Durante los siguientes siglos
comerciantes árabes Conquistadores y
eruditos los difundieron en
Europa era un sistema decimal o de base
10 que podía representar cualquier
número con solo 10 glifos únicos las
posiciones de estos símbolos indican
diferentes potencias de 10 Empezando por
la derecha y aumentando hacia la
izquierda por ejemplo el número 310
se lee 6 * 10 elev 0 1 * 10 elev 1 + 3 *
10 elev
dos un avance clave de este sistema que
fue desarrollado por los mayas de forma
independiente fue el número cero
sistemas de notación posicional más
antiguos que carecían de este símbolo
dejaban un espacio en blanco en su lugar
lo que hacía difícil distinguir entre 63
y 603 o 12 y 120 la comprensión del cero
como valor y marcador de posición hizo
la notación confiable y
consistente es posible usar 10 símbolos
cualesquiera para representar los
números de 0 a nu durante mucho tiempo
los glifos variaron por región muchos
estudiosos concuerdan en que los dígitos
actuales evolucionaron desde los usados
al norte de África durante el Imperio
árabe y en el siglo XV lo que ahora
conocemos como el sistema numérico huar
reemplazó a los números romanos en la
vida cotidiana y se convirtió en el
sistema numérico más usado en el mundo
Pero por qué el sistema hindú árabe
junto con tantos otros usan la base 10
la respuesta más probable es la más
simple eso también explica Por qué los
aztecas usaron base 20 o un sistema
bijes Pero también son posibles otras
bases los números babilónicos eran
sexagesimales o de base 60 mucha gente
se piensa que una base 12 o sistema Dúo
decimal sería una buena idea como el 60
el 12 es un número altamente compuesto
que se puede dividir por 2 3 4 y 6 lo
que lo hace mucho mejor para representar
fracciones comunes ambos sistemas están
en nuestra vida cotidiana desde cómo
medimos los grados y el tiempo hasta en
mediciones comunes como una
docena y la base dos o sistema binario
se usa en todos nuestros dispositivos
digitales aunque los programadores usan
base 8o y base 16 para una anotación más
compacta así que la próxima vez que use
un número grande piense en la enorme
cantidad capturada en estos pocos
símbolos y fíjese si se le ocurre alguna
manera diferente de
representarlo hablando de sistemas
numéricos de dónde proviene el sistema
métrico conozca esta historia fascinante
en este video y suscríbase a nuestro
canal para aprender algo nuevo cada
semana
than